ambassador Bolton thank you very much
for speaking to us next week president
Trump is due to take part in a UK state
visit Theresa May of course will be
leaving office just days later why do
you think she went wrong with her
leadership well that's not a question I
think it's appropriate for me to get
into the president admires Prime
Minister May he's said that on a number
of occasions he admires her
determination and her grit he's tried to
work very closely with her because the
US UK relationship is the most important
bilateral relationship we have and I
think the two of them will have a lot to
discuss next week even though she's
announced her intention to leave the
prime ministership I think we have a lot
of issues in front of us and it's an
important celebration of the 75th
anniversary of d-day and I think the two
of them will have a lot to talk about
of course the brexit negotiations will
be handled by her successor do you think
a No Deal is the best option for Britain
now well I think president Trump's made
it clear he looks forward to the day
when the US and the UK can negotiate a
bilateral trade deal that would be
beneficial to both countries and and to
see the will of the British people
carried out now beyond that I think it's
going to be up to the Conservative Party
in the first instance to pick a new
leader and then to see what what happens
in the negotiation process with the
European Union what kind of leader would
you like to work with in the future we
know that President Trump has once again
today praised Boris Johnson and Nigel
Farage what qualities do you admire in
Boris Johnson well look the president
the president has relationships with
with both of those men as he has with
many people in Britain because of his
long-standing business interest here
he's been a strong supporter of brexit
and I think he really does look forward
to the opportunity to negotiate with a
fully independent Britain outside the
European Union but beyond that I think
at this stage it's obviously a delicate
moment in the leadership selection
process and I'll leave it at that
of course there are US commercial
interests involved in UK US trade deal
that would open up our trade our
medicine of course pharmaceutical
industry as well it has big implications
where America could gain and it has big
implications where Britain could gain
since many of these same pharmaceutical
companies do are based in Great Britain
and do a lot of business in the United
States I just think the two economies
are very much in sync I could imagine
bringing Canada into a three-way deal in
the near future Britain is a global
economic power a global political and
military power and we look forward to a
continued very strong partnership with
the UK there are protests planned next
week here during the state visit the
president is a man who cares about
optics is he concerned about those no
look I think people are going to protest
for one reason or another that's what
free societies are all about and I think
it's the it's a tribute to the strength
of the democratic system in Great
Britain and the United States that these
people are free to protest it's been a
very important few weeks for u.s.
foreign policy
you have pushed for regime change in
Iran you said the North Korea violated
UN resolutions with the recent missile
tests and yet the president said quite
the opposite so who's right well you
know on Iran the president's policy is
not regime change it never has been I've
said many many things over the years
before I took this job on a wide variety
of subjects I've hardly hidden my views
under a bushel basket but in this job
I'm the national security adviser I'm
not the national security decision-maker
and obviously the president dictates the
policy and that's certainly true in
North Korea as well the president is
very determined that neither Iran nor
North Korea will get deliverable nuclear
weapons he has been fully prepared to
negotiate with either of both countries
he said so since the 2016 campaign he's
held two summit meetings with Kim
jong-un a press
than breaking a pair of summits and he's
held fast to the position he's expressed
there that he wants to see all of North
Korea's nuclear weapons program
eliminated so I think his position is
very clear and that's obviously the the
position of the administration your
position on Iranian naval vessels you
say were to blame for damage to oil
tankers in the Gulf of Oman you said
that was an act of aggression but not
one the US was going to respond to so
what would it take for America to
respond well I've said it was almost
certainly the case that Iran was
responsible for the attack on the
tankers we expect that the countries of
the vessels involved Saudi Arabia the
United Arab Emirates Norway will in due
course and I think fairly shortly make
public the results of their
investigations I don't think anybody who
knows the region has any doubt who
staged those attacks or the attacks on
the Saudi pipeline pumping stations
whether Iran or their surrogates we've
made it very clear that this kind of
behavior is not something they should be
engaged in and we've made it
particularly clear that if American
citizens or facilities are threatened or
attacked that there will be a very
strong response back in Washington
Democrats are now pushing for
impeachment proceedings after Robert
Muller said that he wasn't able to
determine whether or not the president
had committed a crime are you preparing
for that eventualities well look I'm not
preparing for it because it's not in my
area responsibility I think the
president's made his position on this
very clear and the Justice Department
and Attorney General bar have made their
position on it clear and I think we'll
see what happens in Congress it's the
political season the 2020 campaign is on
us so fasten your seatbelt President
Trump says it's filthy disgusting word
impeachment do you agree well I think
it's obviously something the Democrats
have to think long and hard about before
they go down this route I don't think
the framers of the Constitution ever
intended impeachment to be
a political process I think they had
something very different in mind
and it's something that having watched
Republicans tried against President
Clinton during his administration and
see it backfire something I think
politicians should reflect on there's
been a lot of discussion in the United
States about you as a hawk in the White
House and Donald Trump as the Dove do
you ever feel isolated
you know whenever these stories appear
in the press I think back to a an old
proverb from Central Asia that goes the
dog's bark and the caravan moves on
you've previously said that when you
enter government you have to accept that
there are things that you're not going
to win are you winning or losing at the
moment I'm having a great time you won't
be drawn on either side nice try and the
state visit what do you hope it will
achieve between the two countries well I
think it will underline the strength of
the bilateral relationship I think it
will make it very clear that the
interest and values of the United
Kingdom in the United States are very
very close regardless of political
currents in either country I think this
is a time of challenge for free
societies around the world and I think
it's very important that everyone
understand just how close our two
countries are it's been a very
problematic period in British political
history a lot of criticism of Teresa
Mays leadership who do you think you'll
see in Downing Street that's a
prediction someone else will have to
make those obviously though a lot of
contact with various members of the
British political establishment we know
that Nigel Farage has been to Washington
that's talk of him agitated for a No
Deal brexit and the gains America might
make do you think that's appropriate for
the president to have dealings with the
likes of Nigel Farage at this delicate
time well the president will do what the
president wants I think it's it's safe
to say that he continues to look forward
to an opportunity to have a bilateral
trade deal with the United Kingdom
that's very important for both countries
and as soon as that's the United Kingdom
is in a position to engage in those
negotiations seriously we're prepared to
do so as well
ambassador Bolton thank you very much
indeed for speaking with us my pleasure